les conspirationnistes salle une fois
plus si un truc qui m'a bouffé le
cerveau je n'arrive plus à dormir et une
fois plus chez une vidéo pour vous en
parlez pour vous sentir moins seul dans
ma tête ça fait longtemps plus qu'on n'a
pas fait une vidéo conspiration aux
théories du complot tout ça franchement
je pense ça va être la meilleure de tout
parce que il ya un tel mystère autour
que c'est génial
autant les gens qui croient à
l'interprète je trouve ça con car tu as
juste à envoyer un [ __ ] de satellites
en l'air pour comprendre que c'est faux
autant là j'adore connaissez-vous les
pyramides il y en a donc lundi certaines
sont vieilles de plusieurs milliers
d'années des plus connus sont sur le
plateau de gizeh en egypte
on peut trouver les pyramides de khéops
la plus grande celle de khephren et
celle de mickey en hausse alors avant de
commencer à parler des pyramides
pourquoi elle attise la curiosité de
beaucoup beaucoup de scientifiques est
la mienne le bon conte de squeeze c'est
très mystérieuse qui est autour des
pyramides on ne sait toujours pas
comment elles ont été construites à
l'époque on a des théories mais on n'a
jamais mis en pratique la théorie c'est
à dire que l'on pense qu'ils ont fait
comme ça mais on n'a jamais essayé de le
faire nous de la même manière ce qui
fait que tout ça c'est des théories à
des spéculations autour de certaines
théories plus que d'autres mais c'est ça
qui fait le charme des pyramides c'est
ce [ __ ] de mystère que yahoo sauf
qu'il ya des faits qu'on peut constater
en allant voir les pyramides qui
remettent en question certaines choses
qu'on a affirmé qu'ils sont peut-être
pas vrai peut-être qu'on s'est trompé
j'ai peut-être faire des erreurs dans ce
que je dis j'ai peut-être dire des trucs
où je suis un peu à côté de la plaque
mais ne m'en voulez pas voilà je veux
juste parler d'un sujet que qui me
fascine et je vais essayer dire le moins
de conneries possible et vous avez quoi
si vous voulez me corriger certains
trucs pour plutôt apporter des
précisions n'hésitez pas dans les
commentaires je veux que cet espace
commentaire sur le meilleur de tous
youtube maintenant que ceci est dit
comment sont les pyramides sont des
tombeaux pour les pharaons ça je pense
que vous le savez la plus grande
pyramide serait le tombeau de khéops
pourquoi je dis quel besoin criant je ne
sais pas mais je suis excité de vous en
parler la grande pyramide de khéops très
vieille d'environ 4500 ans elle est
faite de plus de 2 millions de blocs de
pierres différent de formes et de
tailles différentes et vous allez voir
dans quelques instants que ça n'a pas du
tout été fait à la rage que tout était
parfaitement calculé d'après la plupart
des égyptologues qui vont détester cette
vidéo elle aurait été construite en
vingt ans pourquoi maintenant et pas
plus parce que c'est la durée du règne
de khéops et si c'est vraiment son
tombeau emma la construction n'aurait
pas pu durer plus longtemps que son
règne 20 ans pour empiler 2 millions de
blocs de pierre pesant chacun entre 2 et
10 tonnes c'est bon pour vous alors il
ya des stades très connus
impressionnante qui montre que si
c'était vraiment le cas si ça avait
vraiment été fait en 20 ans à raison de
12 heures de travail par jour
tous les jours de l'année ça
représenterait un bloc extrait tailler
émis à sa place toutes les 2 minutes 30
peut-être peut-être qu'ils étaient
vraiment trop mal et c'est ça qui est
génial c'est qu'autour des pyramides ya
du mystère parce qu'on se dit [ __ ]
mais alors comment ils ont fait les mecs
étaient en slip
bon revenons en aux cailloux là il ya
deux millions de blocs et il a bien
fallu des trucs et pas assez bloc et
sont pas allés les chercher haut de la
pyramide ils sont allés les chercher
dans des cavernes de granby à des
centaines de kilomètres au sud de la
pyramide c'est à dire qu'ils allaient
extraire les pierres là bas et qu'il les
transportait sur plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres et il ne connaissait pas la
roue alors il ya plusieurs théories sur
la façon dont ils ont transporté ces
énormes blocs de pierre sur des
centaines de kilomètres la première fois
qu'ils auraient utilisé un traîneau de
halage en bois qui faisait glisser sur
le sol à l'aide de cordes en chambre
fallait donc aménager des voies sur de
très grandes distances et surtout une
fois arrivés vers la pyramide construire
un chemin pour amener les pierres en
haut de cette dernière sauf qu'à une
autre théorie qui vient contrer cette
théorie là en montrant que les chemins
permettant d'acheminer les pierres vers
le haut de la pyramide se serait
affaissé peu à peu à cause du poids les
pierres et donc il aurait fallu les
reconstruire pas mal de fois mais
tellement de fois sur 20 ans que ça
aurait demandé autant d'efforts de
construire les chemins que ne construit
la pyramide le tout toujours en vingt
ans donc ça fait beaucoup de chose à
faire quand même en 20 ans [ __ ]
aujourd'hui on pense que leurs seuls
outils étaient les suivants un burin de
cuivre un maillet de pierres et des
cordes
il aurait fait ce truc là avec ces
outils là comme nous avec les outils les
technologies d'aujourd'hui il nous
faudrait 25 ans pour la construire et le
travail serait beaucoup moins précis que
ce que eux ont fait pourquoi pas c'est
peut-être un beau casse tête peut-être
qu'ils avaient vraiment que ces outils
là et qu'ils étaient juste beaucoup plus
malin que nous toutes manières garde en
tête qu'aucune théorie n'est prouvée
mais qui ajuste des théories qui
paraissent plus vrai que d'autres mais
rien n'est prouvé donc on peut tout
imaginer c'est pour ça que j'adore les
pyramides alors il ya aussi des sites
autour des trois pyramides ou
qui sont par exemple des sanctuaires qui
sont fait de murs sauf que les méthodes
utilisées pour faire ses murs n'est pas
comme nous la manière la plus simple de
faire un mur aujourd'hui en fait c'est
de faire des pierres de la même taille
de les mettre les unes sur les autres et
de les fixer avec du ciment à l'époque
ils n'ont pas du tout fait ça ils ont
découpé des pierres avec des formes qui
ne sont pas du tout les mêmes
et pourtant elle sent boîte parfaitement
c'est une précision c'est chirurgicale
et il n'y a pas de ciment entre les
pierres pourtant on ne peut même pas y
passer une feuille de papier même
incroyable avec moi qui trouve ça
incroyable bras tous les maçons
l'acquérir la vidéo avouez que c'est
quand même incroyable
si ça devait rassurer on l'a vu la
pyramide a été construite à base de 2
millions de blogs de formes et de
tailles différentes et le fait que ce
soit hétérogènes ça permet tout
simplement à la pyramide de résister aux
séismes
elle a traversé des milliers d'années
des séismes dans l'inconnu et pourtant
elle est encore là en état magnifique
par rapport à son ancienneté et pourtant
les égyptologues et historiens nous
disent que les égyptiens ne connaissait
pas l'anti sismique c'est à dire cette
science qui permet de résister aux
séismes au tremblement de terre au
mouvement des plaques tectoniques
comment ils ont fait alors
autre point dans ces fameux lieux qui a
autour des pyramides on trouve des
pierres dans lequel il ya des coupes
vraiment net qu'on arrive aujourd'hui à
faire avec nos outils modernes donc des
six qui tourne extrêmement villes qui
sont extrêmement solides et c'est bon je
connais pas trop le th de pierre mais
voilà je sais qu'aujourd'hui on arrive à
faire des coupes à cnet dans des pierres
très très solide mais à l'époque je le
rappelle il avait ça comment ont-ils
fait pour faire des coupures sinnett
dans des roches si dense et surtout dans
des quantités pareil alors qu'il n'avait
qu'un mallet de pierre et un burin alors
encore une fois peut-être que c'était
leur outil mais qu'ils avaient quand
même des techniques particulières pour
réussir à couper de cette manière là la
pierre ou alors ils avaient d'autres
outils dont on n'a pas retrouvé de
traces et qui leur permettait de faire
ça mais on ne sait pas autre chose aussi
à propos de ces outils c'est que la
pyramide est orienté presque
parfaitement vers le nord vers le pôle
magnétique nord mais à l'époque il n'y
avait pas de compagnie n'avait pas de
boussole pour mesurer pour voir où était
le nord l'ouest l'est et le sud
et pourtant elle est décalée que de cinq
centièmes de degrés par rapport au nord
parfait pour donner un ordre d'idée
l'observatoire de paris qui a été
construit au xviie siècle lui est
décalée de 25 centièmes de degrés par
rapport au nord alors qu'on est des
milliers d'années plus tard on n'arrive
pas à faire aussi bien que c'est ça qui
font bon ok le car n'a compris la
construction c'est trop bizarre tous ces
blocs tous ces trucs mais peut-être
qu'ils ont fait peut-être qu'ils ont
tout simplement vraiment transporter
tout ça qu'ils ont
vraiment réussi à tailler pouces avec
leur bureau parce qu'ils étaient
extrêmement nombreux avec des
architectes incroyable avec des méthodes
incroyable avec une rigueur
exceptionnelle et peut-être qu'ils ont
vraiment réussi cet exploit en fait
alors là on est juste sur la théorie de
la construction qui est la théorie
principale de sa comment ils ont fait il
ya des trucs quand même bien plus
bizarre que ça prenne vraiment la grande
pyramide de gizeh indiquerez les
équinoxes les équinoxes c'est le moment
de l'année où le soleil se trouve le
plus à l'est
en fait les phases de la pyramide serait
légèrement courbée vers l'intérieur et
c'est ce qui permet de créer une ombre
quand on est en jour d'équinoxe ce qu'il
faut avec ça c'est que c'est encore plus
dur de faire les pyramides si les façons
légèrement creusé vers l'intérieur les
tories montrent qu'en fait il y avait un
revêtement sur la pyramide qui s'est
effondré avec avec le temps en fait les
murs se sont tout simplement tasser vers
l'intérieur attiré vers l'intérieur de
la pyramide ce qui aurait créé ces
petits angles sur les parois et que le
fait que ça crée une ombre uniquement le
jour de l'année où le soleil est le plus
à l'aise serait un pur hasard
peut-être en vrai peut-être n'en sais
rien c'est ça qui est bien c'est que
tout est possible et imaginable autres
trucs très étrange c'est la théorie de
la corrélation doriot certains
égyptologues sont mis d'accord à dire
que c'est pas le fruit du hasard tu
aurais une corrélation entre
l'emplacement vue du ciel du site des
pyramides de gizeh et les étoiles de la
constellation d'orion et ça c'est le
début d'une réflexion qui montre que
cette civilisation avait une
connaissance incroyable désastre le site
de gizeh serait tout simplement une
horloge astronomique permettant de
savoir la position de la terre au cours
d'un cycle de presque 26 milles et que
la tête de sfax dont on n'a pas encore
parlé et qui se trouve sur le site de
gizeh aurait quelque chose à voir avec
tout ça la fameuse tête du sphinx donc
et a perdu sa s'incline hier je sais
plus le nom gaulois ya plein de mots qui
m'échappent mais vous comprenez grâce
aux images merci clément n'aurait pas
été construite en même temps que la
grande pyramide de gizeh elle aurait été
construite plusieurs milliers d'années
avant leur garde la tête de sphinx
serait l'aiguillé de cette horloge et
les points de repère serait la
constellation du taureau du lion du
scorpion et du verso on voit que sur le
sphinx il ya un caillou qui ressort on
appelle ça le coeur du sphinx en arabe
al kalba l'assad j'espère bien dire
désolé je suis humble tout fragile je ne
sais pas par l'arabe et je trouve que
c'est aussi le nom qu'il donnait à
l'étoile la plus brillante de la
constellation du taureau étoiles qu'on
appelle aujourd'hui regulus quand on
prend le regard du sphinx comme
indicateur est comme référence dans le
cycle l'étoile la plus brillante de la
constellation du lion qu'on obtient donc
un cycle de 26000 année alors peut-être
que c'est simplement le fruit du hasard
et qu'on s'imagine des choses ou
peut-être que à l'époque lors de la
construction de ces énormes bénéfices
il avait une connaissance parfaite des
astres et c'était totalement voulue
alors pourquoi vouloir repérer la
position de la terre sur un cycle de 26
mille ans ca c
bon ok on ne sait pas répondre là on
part dans les grosses théorie du complot
mais des théories qui montre qu'en fait
tout les vingt-six mille ans les pôles
magnétiques de la terre s'inverserait ce
qui ferait qu'on ne serais plus protégée
par l'atmosphère pendant un certain
temps et ce qui anéantirait toute forme
de vie à la surface de la terre est en
gros la terre redémarrer à zéro
ainsi soit-il j'ai envie de vous dire on
sera déjà dead d'ici là sauf si la fin
du succès dans cinq ans mais ce n'est
pas le cas je sais plus à combien on en
est mais on n'est pas du tout aux 26
milan autre chose d'intéressant on a
trouvé sur le sphinx des traces
d'érosion liées à de l'eau ce qui montre
qu'un jour ils auraient été ensevelies
sous l'eau sauf que pour qu'ils soient
ensevelis sous l'eau il aurait fallu que
le niveau des océans soit plus haute de
160 mètres et la dernière fois qu'il a
été aussi haut c'était à 700 mille ans
est ce que le sphinx serait donc 700
mille ans où est ce que pendant des
milliers d'années qui ont suivi sa
construction le climat était très
différent il y avait énormément de plus
est ce que les pyramides aurait elle
aussi 700 mille ans est ce que les
égyptiens auraient donc en fait n'ont
pas construit la pyramide en 20 ans mais
essayez de faire revêtement de cette
dernière pour l'entretenir on ne sait
pas et c'est beaucoup de questions à
laquelle on n'a pas de réponse le
cerveau n'aime pas l'inconnu d'ailleurs
l'appareil de lille à l'adhérent on a vu
ça votre notre cerveau n'aime pas
d'inconnus et donc on veut tout le temps
trouver des explications à des choses
sauf que des fois on n'arrive pas à en
trouver mais on fait comme si on en
avait trouvé des amis c'est la fin de
cette vidéo sur les pyramides de gizeh
cheval savoir plus n'hésitez pas le
musée le câble alors je trouve ça
passionnant comme sujet il ya énormément
documentaire énormément d'égyptologues
qu'on a interviewé d'architectes
d'historiens de beaucoup de gens
vraiment bien plus compétents que moi
qu'on parle d'un sujet et c'est très
intéressant de voir toutes leurs
opinions de voir toutes les théories et
miss de voir comme ça les passionnés
comme il ya des gens qui bossent au
moment où on se parle en masse pour
essayer de résoudre ces fameux mystère
de répondre à ces fameuses questions je
suis désolé si j'ai dit les médecins
encore une fois je me suis beaucoup
documenté et tout mais je reste un gros
amateur je mettrais quelques liens dans
la description ci en a qui veulent se
documenter un peu plus et avoir plus
d'infos sur ça et je tenais à faire
cette vidéo parce que tous les gens qui
ne valident pas les théories validé en
masse par beaucoup d'égyptologues
passent pour des fous pour des illuminés
je crois qu'ils ont même un nom les
pyramides au sujet pas koala est en fait
ça montre juste que quand on n'est pas
d'accord avec la théorie principale on
passe pour un fou mais quand cette
théorie n'a pas été prouvée je vois pas
en quoi tout ça c'est de la folie en
fait on peut tout imaginer et c'est ça
que je trouve passionnant avec cette
théorie là et c'est pas pour moi de la
théorie du complot c'est de la théorie
tout court et pour ça je trouvais ça
amusant d'en parler aujourd'hui en vidéo
bref je suis très curieux n'hésitez pas
à me donner des news du coup sûr tout ça
moi aussi je me tiendrai informé
peut-être qu'on reprenne vidéo ça se
trouve dans des années où on a
redécouvert un peu plus de choses en
bref est ce que ça a été construit par
des gens comme nous ou par des gens
comme nous mais bien
plus avancé technologiquement parlant
que nous mais qui n'ont laissé aucune
trace ou alors est-ce que ça a été
construit par une civilisation
extraterrestre ou alors est-ce que ça a
vraiment été construit par des gens qui
avait les outils et les moyens qu'on
pense qu'ils avaient et qu'on a juste
toujours pas trouvé avec quelle
technique
ils ont réussi on ne sait pas et ça
c'est génial qui a un gros doute sur ça
c'est trop bien quoi on peut croire ce
qu'on veut et ça j'adore vous dis à
bientôt portez vous bien tuant les amis
gros bisous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]